[Musik]
sebastian lege greift zum laser und
verpackt biogemüse endlich ohne plastik
völlig elektrisiert testet sebastian wie
weit er mit der technik gehen kann
[Musik]
ich werde sie weiterhin lege katja mast
wir müssen für die supermärkte alles
verpackt okay wir versuchen es anders zu
machen so wie hier zum beispiel super
das wäre es nicht besser aber da war
auch wieder stücke ja oder so wieder ein
label ok ich habe aber gehört ihr habt
ihr noch eine variante die information
aus produkt zu bringen die sonst fast
keiner hat er gesagt das ist unser
geheimnis und die würde ich gerne
forster aus süßkartoffeln etwa halten
aufkleber nur schlecht darum kommen sie
aufs fließband
im inneren dieser maschine wird nicht
verschweißt oder geklebt sondern
gebrannt mit laserstrahlen das ergebnis
gestochen scharfe bio labels
und das auch noch blitzschnell 7000
süßkartoffeln pro stunde schafft die
neuartige maschine
wahnsinn was wir machen
label ohne aufkleber das nenne ich mal
ein aufreger und ohne plastik super und
anhand der eingebrannten nummer lässt
sich die herkunft der produkte sogar bis
kurz vor dem verzehr zurückverfolgen den
geschmack und das bleibt auch gut und
ich konnte es erst wieder ab
wir können das einfach klein bisschen
ausmachen aber fruchtfleisch bleibt
orange wahnsinn wirklich nichts zu sehen
das kann man wirklich nicht sehen
hier haben wir dass die laser bio logo
und keine rückstände an der kartoffel
süßkartoffeln sind die eine sache
doch wie ergeht es sensibleren produkten
ich habe etwas mitgebracht schau mal
berg für sich köln was meint ihr kann
man das laser könnte das einfach
versuchen okay machen wir das so ist der
laser nicht so brutal für samtweiche für
sich
[Musik]
im gegenteil er hinterlässt fast keine
spuren das logo ist kaum erkennbar
bei zucchini oder kürbis funktioniert
die laserkanone ungleich besser der
strahl kann dem härtegrad der schale und
der konsistenz der produkte angepasst
werden
darum funktioniert er bei fast allen
obst und gemüsesorten mit fester schale
und das laser logo kratzt buchstäblich
nur an der oberfläche es beeinflusst
weder die haltbarkeit noch den geschmack
[Musik]
auch smoothies kann die industrie mit
strom noch günstiger und gesünder
herstellen die technik ist neu und
hochspannend produktentwickler sebastian
lege ist auf dem weg nach quakenbrück in
niedersachsen dort erforschen ingenieure
der firma elia wie man lebensmittel mit
strom konserviert meist werden säfte
pasteurisiert also durch kurzzeitiges
erhitzen haltbar gemacht der nachteil
vitamine und aromen leiden unter der
behandlung eine andere methode mit
extrem hohem druck schon zwar vitamine
und aromen aber für sie funktioniert nur
bei plastikflaschen die entwickler in
quakenbrück versprechen säfte und
smoothies die gleichzeitig haltbar und
vitaminreich sind das macht sebastian
neugierig
stephan ich habe gesagt ihr könnt
lebensmittel durch strom aufwerten wie
funktioniert eurosystem wir nutzen
elektrische energie in form von kurzen
pulsen um zellmembran zu öffnen
durch einsatz von strom oder von
elektrischer energie und es kann eben
bei der herstellung von saft eingesetzt
werden der trick heißt pulsierende
elektrische felder durch hochspannungs
impulse entstehen löcher in den
felswänden von bakterien und keimen die
schädlinge sterben der saft bleibt
frisch während der saft durch die
maschine fließt wird der kurzen impulsen
von 8.000 volt ausgesetzt aber die
geöffneten toren in den zellwänden
lassen nicht nur bakterien und
mikroorganismen sterben sondern sie
setzen auch mehr flüssigkeit aus den 15
frei
ein gläschen frischen saft und brezeln
auf der zone aromatisch schmecke ich
jetzt kein unterschied
die aromen wurde nicht beeinträchtigt so
schmeckt richtig guter saft frisch nicht
irgendwie aus konzentraten aufgefüllt
sondern in der pfiffigen physikalischen
idee haltbar gemacht ohne chemie ohne
hitze da schmeckt die zukunft doch der
hochspannungs trick kann noch mehr zum
beispiel bei der pommes frites
produktion für hersteller ist bruch
normalerweise ein unvermeidliches
ärgernis doch durch die porösen
zellwände werden die kartoffeln weicher
und lassen sich besser schneiden kleine
und verwertbare bruchstücke sind passé
auch die garzeit verkürzt sich und weil
die glatteren schnittkanten beim
frittieren weniger fett aufnehmen sind
die pommes gesünder
sie enthalten sogar weniger
gesundheitsschädliches acrylamid
was mit anderen lebensmitteln passiert
finden die forscher gerade erst heraus
beim auspressen von obst und gemüse etwa
das mit hochspannung behandelt wurde
erhält man deutlich mehr saft bei roter
beete beispielsweise rund sieben prozent
eine clevere methode um aus wertvollen
rohstoffen mehr herauszuholen
achtet ihr auf die verpackung bei eurem
gemüse und was ist euch beim kauf von
smoothies und setzten wichtig sagt es
uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips